so we got a chance to play state of
decay - with co-op and uh you know every
time I play with Aaron something bad
always happens
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
every time I play with you Aaron like I
always like have this really embarassing
depth and you know it's gotta push games
as far as you can until they push back
one of my biggest concerns going into
this press trip was looking at people's
co-op footage of state of decay and
seeing them wielding some of the heavier
weapons from the Lifeline DLC and just
mowing through zombies not really caring
much I was really worried that this was
gonna be too easy and I'm glad to say
that after this event I can say that
stay of decay too was a really hard game
yeah
and co-op it's it's a really hard game
honestly if we had gone for another two
hours so we played for a couple of hours
and we started in the mid game section
of it but if we go on for a couple more
hours and I've played through all of
state of decay and the DLC we would have
died our survivors would have been done
our base was in bad shape by the end of
this session and it was because we tried
to go out and mess around yeah it was
basically like we had like a junker and
it was just slowly starting to lose
parts over the course of like us trying
to make it down the road that's what I
liked about this game is that it really
makes you think about you know whether
whether you want to like you know go in
like you know try to raid this office
building or like maybe a schoolyard or
whatever and see if there's a supplies
there versus like the risk of actually
trying to do that and because actually
going there could mean like you know
your character is probably gonna die
because not only are there zombies but
there was also special zombies way more
special zombies like there's the
juggernaut which we encountered a few
times during our co-op experiences but
also new plague zombies which are
basically like you know sort of the sort
of super zombies like you know they're
way faster the way more aggressive
they're stronger and they can infect
your character which you'll eventually
turn them into zombies as well the
developers did talk a little bit about
how they've upped the game of those
zombies I think some of that is in
response to their being co-op like the
juggernauts in particular were savages
versus cars but could be fairly easily
killed like I hit one with a 50 caliber
sniper rifle and it dropped to its knees
and then they can beam a lady to death
pretty quickly
other ones that are tricky are the like
the bloaters which are returning from
the first game if you hit them with your
car your car basically gets cooked and
you have to bail on your car because if
you stay in no matter how fast you drive
the the gas cloud stays with that and
burns your car and then screamers are
about the same you definitely have to
shoot them before they paralyze your
team but they do hold more zombies than
in the pass game and then hunters uh a
zig zag a lot more when you spot them at
a distance they are harder to hit as
they come at you this game throws a lot
at you so in the mid game what we were
told is that sound matters a lot more I
think they ease you into it a little bit
early in the game and then as the game
progresses the louder you get the more
zombies are spawned noise is actually a
big factor in this game now compared to
the first game there's a thing where you
can actually search through supplies
much faster like in in this game and if
you keep abusing that feature where you
actually just sort of cycle through like
you know like boxes or lockers then
you'll create a lot of noise which will
attract you know pretty much all the
zombies in the area which then they'll
all come you know basically gunning for
you let's talk about how you stay alive
in this game as you know state of decay
is a game about you know making 19 runs
and on the 20 if you flip your car to
ditch and get permadeath so it's tough
but a lot more of it focuses on
maintaining vehicles now the game starts
with a limited amount of vehicles as
before but you can repair vehicles all
the way from a burnt Hulk but you do
need these kits so in a central part of
every run that we made was packing the
trunk of the vehicle with with fuel
which is new and repair kits if you have
those two with you and you'll probably
go through both of them and anyone give
and run if things get hairy then your
team has a good chance of surviving I
don't like the fact and this was a
design decision not a bug that co-op
players can't do anything when they're
riding in a car other than open the door
yeah you know which we had some fun with
[Music]
let's talk about the pros and cons of
coop so how online co-op works is that
there's a host and then there's a guest
player the guest player comes in the the
hosts version of the player space so
everything the host has done that's all
set and the guest character will come in
and basically they'll inhabit that
existing space and when the guest
character comes to the the hosts main
outpost which is where you know their
supplies like all their their characters
and survivors are so when they go into
the outposts supply locker they won't
take any of the supplies that the host
character has they'll basically use
supplies that come from their version of
the game there won't be any points where
you know the guest character will steal
any supplies from the host character or
vice versa so everyone's pretty much
coming in with what they came in with
and that goes both ways too because
they're actually not helping you that
much build your base and ultimately
winning or losing in game has to do with
in large part your ability to build
build mod and maintain your base the
other thing is that the guest character
is pulling their own people so for
example in our session I kill the main
character good ol Ozzy you know you know
wielding a shotgun and he died like
really early on in our co-op session you
had infected with blood plague and I
didn't recognize it until you killed him
because he actually turned on us in the
Nova fight yeah but the thing is I was
able to play as that character like you
know later on because I was pulling him
from my version of game in at in my game
he hasn't he didn't die like he was fine
like you know he's still in relatively
good spirits despite the you know the
circumstances they were in it's very
similar to how far cry 5 did it the host
has his version of the game and the
guest comes into it as as just that a
guest the thing that does carry over is
that the guests will be able to you know
keep influence which can be spent on the
resources in their outpost back in their
version the game I don't like I don't
feel like they have to be this safe I
think if you're inviting a friend into
your game you should just be able to let
them build your base and work out of
your community Locker and you know like
why not I feel like it's a little bit
too safe to do that and I feel like it
makes it a little bit boring for the
guests sometimes
alright let's talk about guns actually
talk to the guy who made all of them in
this game and what he said was there
were something like a hundred weapons or
more in lifeline what they've done is
they've toned it way down so it's more
like the original game but the guns all
have modifications on them now so right
now they're randomly assigned so you'll
pick up a wide variety of a fewer
weapons but with more variants of them
but he did say that they coated a
modding system into it that's not
implemented yet so it looks like and
they don't have an announced feature
date maybe at some point you'll be able
to actually select those mods for the
weapons or craft those mods but at the
end of the day the guns are really cool
we played with a grenade launcher we
played with a 50 caliber sniper rifle we
had a shotgun with a huge drum and like
I said we expended a lot of ammo and by
the end we were almost out of ammo so
you can have a lot of fun but you got to
watch it and it's it's that classic
state of decay thing where where it'll
punish you later if you just don't pay
attention yeah really this is a game
about balancing resources so even though
they give you plenty of like weapons and
you know which includes firearms and
melee weapons you know you can have all
of that and like you know have all the
ammo and everything but if you don't
have like food medicine actual building
material for your outposts and making
sure the morale is high for you know all
the survivors in the outposts and all
those weapons are don't mean anything in
a long run because you know if you you
know if you can't keep track and keep
take care of what you have then it's
it's just not gonna matter so in a lot
of cases sometimes it's better to leave
like firearms that you do find in just
in favor of like you know getting food
and like you know other resources that
you can take back to your outposts you
know because that's in the long run
that's a better option for you yeah
for that
alright so that was our look at state of
decay to out May 22nd let us know what
you guys think
are you a big state of decay fan would
you prefer they continue with their life
line style DLC or do you like the
original idea of just building up and
getting will down by zombies let's talk
about in the comments below and let us
know what else you'd like to see in our
state of decay to coverage in the near
future alright thanks for watching guys
[Music]